the first movie begins in a dark and
dilapidated facility where a nurse of
some sorts is administering artificial
semen to a woman oh God here we go again
here we go again after the procedure is
done a guard arrives there puts The
Woman in Chains and rudely takes her
away along the way she notices other
women held in captivity with pipes
attached to their chests it appears as
if the facility is harvesting milk from
the women following this the woman whose
name is revealed to be Lisa is locked
inside a cage her hands are then tied to
the fence making sure she is not able to
move an inch there are several other
women in the room as well most of which
have lost their sanity due to the abuse
they've been receiving day in and day
out for instance they are Zapped or
beaten up from time to time by the
guards no one knows how they came here
or where this place is the only thing
they do know is that they have to get
out of here but it is not an easy task
one night a woman suddenly goes goes
into labor and starts screaming at the
top of her lungs Lisa tries to comfort
her from the other cell but it doesn't
work soon the guards along with the
nurse arrive and take her out of the
cell they then force her to deliver the
child causing her excruciating pain
after a lot of struggle a baby boy is
taken out but before the woman can see
him he is dumped into the bin and killed
oh my oh my God Game of Thrones has
nothing on this it turns out these
captors only keep the girls because
their main aim is to harvest milk from
them if a boy is born he is immediately
disposed of after they leave the
devastated mother begs Lisa to choke her
and end her suffering but the latter is
hesitant another night a woman is seen
lying unconscious on the floor one of
the guards arrives there and orders her
to get up but as expected she is too
weak to respond enraged he grabs her
forcefully and takes her to another room
possibly to kill her Lisa watches all of
this go down and becomes terrified she
fears that she will never ever make it
out of this place alive however with the
day's passing she loses her sense of
fear and starts plotting an Escape Plan
one day she fakes having a contraction
and lures a guard towards her and as
soon as he opens the door she delivers a
surprise kick to his head knocking him
out Lisa is the Chuck Norris of boob
Farmers the other women are exhilarated
by the attack and they start chanting
for Lisa so with vengeance in her eyes
she takes the guard's knife and finishes
him off with it Lisa then takes his keys
and proceeds to free all the women but
right then she hears someone approaching
and hides behind the door it is another
guard who has arrived to check what is
causing the commotion when he sees his
friend's lifeless body on the floor he
is taken aback suddenly Lisa attacks him
from behind with a metal chain and
eventually strangles him to death Lisa
is the Bruce Willis of boob Farmers she
then hands the keys to one of the women
and finally exits the place outside Lisa
comes across a long Corridor with
several doors on both sides as she peeks
through each of them she sees some
gut-wrenching scenes through one door
she Witnesses a guard brutally killing a
woman while through another she sees
hundreds of unconscious women strapped
to chairs pipes are fitted to their
chests and milk is being pumped out of
them horrified Lisa immediately exits
the room and enters the next one where
she comes across a scared looking girl
it appears as if she was born in the
facility to one of the victims Lisa
tries to comfort the girl saying that
she will rescue her but right then a
guard arrives and takes her away in the
next scene when Lisa wakes up
surprisingly she notices the guard lying
in a pool of his own blood turns out the
woman she had freed earlier got hold of
a knife and killed him the two women
then regroup and start devising a plan
to escape they know that it is going to
be an extremely difficult task which
might result in their demise but seeing
the desperate conditions inside the
facility they are willing to take that
risk anything is better better than the
booby farm right then the nurse from
earlier enters the room to check up on
her patients when her back is turned the
two women grab hold of her and
forcefully cut her tongue out why they
then lock her inside one of the cages
making sure she can neither Escape nor
scream in the final scene we learn the
actual purpose of the facility turns out
they harvest milk from women to
manufacture a beauty cream product
called lactic Vitae this product
promises to revitalize one's skin in
just a matter of hours something which
their competitors cannot I've heard this
is also how McDonald's makes McFlurries
good luck ever looking at a McFlurry
again the same way this movie was based
on real life events oh no millions of
cows are slaughtered all across the
world but the manner in which they are
treated is inhumane they are forcefully
brought to a camp they are artificially
inseminated they are given very little
food and always beaten up and abused
their male calves are immediately
discarded and finally they are executed
when they cannot produce any more milk
the herd depicts the brutal way in which
they are treated using female humans as
an example at the start of the second
movie we are introduced to a couple Ben
and Rachel they are cooking dinner
together while talking about different
things suddenly there is a knock on the
door the couple is shocked because they
weren't expecting anyone at this time of
night Ben asks Rachel to keep cooking
and walks towards the window on seeing
the person his entire demeanor changes
and the excitement from a few seconds
ago leaves his face outside stands a guy
holding the gift box and a grim
expression on his face Ben recognizes
him as someone named Sean he tells
Rachel about Sean's arrival which
surprises her as well she states that
she doesn't want to see him so Ben takes
it upon himself to deal with The
Uninvited Guest hey buddy knock knock
piss off Sean Sean awkwardly greets him
and asks if it was a bad time to come to
the house it was most definitely a bad
time but then asks him to come inside
just to be polite Sean enters the house
and looks around awkwardly thinking of a
way to hand bend the gift box when there
is no special occasion he asks if Rachel
is around and when Ben says no he
breathes a sigh of relief as they talk
we find out that they had a conflict
some time ago and were not on good terms
they haven't talked since the incident
hence Sean's sudden arrival was
surprising to the couple after some
seconds of awkwardly talking about the
interior of the house Sean apologizes
for what he did when they last met he
then finally acknowledges the Box in his
hands and says that it is a gift from
his side Ben takes the Box still unsure
what is the point of the gift they have
nothing else to talk about so he
politely asks the guest if he wants
something to drink after Sean declines
they fall into complete silence having
had enough of the awkwardness Ben
bluntly asks him if he is okay the guy
says he is doing great but asks Ben to
open the presents in front of him oh God
don't do it Ben don't do it buddy
without asking many questions Ben sits
down to open it he tries to read the
letter first but Sean claims that the
letter would only make sense after
looking at the gift so Ben tears the
poorly wrapped paper and opens the box
to his surprise he sees nothing inside
not because the box is empty but because
it is too dark to look inside confused
as to how it is possible Ben turns the
Box around but no matter the lighting he
cannot see what is inside of it he asks
Sean what the box is but gets no reply
instead the Shady guy runs away from the
house hurriedly after he leaves Rachel
comes inside and asks him what happened
but Ben is too busy trying to figure out
the box he brings out a flashlight and
flashes it into the box but even then
the contents are not visible following
that Ben brings out a pencil and drops
it into the box but it makes no noise at
all it is almost as if the box is a
tunnel that leads somewhere the couple
looks at it in confusion not sure what
they should do next Ben tries to put his
hand inside but Rachel stops him because
it doesn't seem safe just then Ben
remembers the card that he received with
the box he opens it and reads a letter
addressed to him by Sean in the letter
Sean apologizes for everything that has
happened between them and claims that he
has to give the box to someone else he
also asks Ben to not take his eyes off
the box at any cost because when he is
not looking it moves the couple is
confused as to how a box can move but
just then the pencil from earlier rolls
over to Ben's feet when he looks back at
the box to his utmost horror a person is
peeking from inside it gosh
the couple is terrified they look at
each other and try to communicate with
the person but he does not speak he
simply stares at them with sweat
dripping down his face Ben quickly calls
Sean but it goes straight to voicemail
meanwhile Rachel realizes that the
stranger hasn't taken his eyes off Ben
for the entire time she inquires what
the person wants but her husband is as
clueless as she is scared Ben calls Sean
again but while he is at it he hears
Rachel ask the same question this is
when it finally Dawns on him that the
box is making him hear things everything
that he said some seconds ago is being
repeated in his head worried that the
stranger May attack any time Ben takes
his keys ready to drive away with Rachel
however when he calls to her she doesn't
move she says that they are always
supposed to watch The Box according to
the letter so leaving it unattended
could be dangerous just to see what
happens when they look away they turn
towards each other for a few seconds
when they look back the and has his
hands on the box implying that he is
trying to come out so Ben asks Rachel to
be with the Box while he goes to Sean's
Place [__] you Ben you do it he makes
her sit on a chair and hands her a knife
for protection although the task is a
scary one Rachel bravely takes her place
and waits for Ben to return in the next
scene Ben finally connects to Sean over
the phone and explains that the box is
telling them things and a person is
coming out of it Sean is shocked because
he didn't know the Box could speak and
the only reason he gave it to Ben was
because he thought Rachel wasn't around
when he finds out the Ben has left
Rachel alone with the box he freaks out
it is then revealed that since the box
was gifted to Ben it doesn't move only
when he is watching it realizing that
his wife is in danger Ben quickly turns
the car around and drives home Sean from
the other side yells at him not to go
back but Ben doesn't listen when he
finally gets home the room is dark and
the light switch is broken using a
flashlight he looks around and sees that
the box is missing and Rachel is nowhere
to be seen he opens the basement door
and calls for her she replies from the
bedroom and sounds completely normal
when she stops talking Ben slowly makes
his way downstairs and into the bedroom
but to his surprise the room is empty
then he hears a noise from the bathroom
and carefully goes into check he sees
the guy from The Box who is now out in
the open Ben tries to maintain eye
contact but looks away startled by a
noise The Stranger disappears in a split
second and he is left alone Ben quickly
tries to run upstairs but sees Shadows
of some people coming down towards him
they stop moving when he looks at them
just like the stranger from the Box on
the other side of the hallway is the
stranger who also walks towards Ben
since he cannot look in both directions
at once they eventually catch up to him
and this screen goes black lesson
learned never accept boxes from dudes
named Sean the third movie starts in a
Serene environment where half-eaten food
and drinks are spilled nearby it appears
as if someone was forcefully taken away
from there there is also a pond in the
area which turn turns out to be a
popular swimming spot for locals some
time later a chubby looking cute girl
arrives there with excitement in her
eyes she is looking forward to taking a
swim in this sweltering heat but she is
also self-conscious about her appearance
prompting her to look around and check
if anybody is nearby after the girl
concludes that she is the only one there
she changes into her swimwear and
proceeds towards the pond however just
as she is about to dive in a middle-aged
man pops out of the water the two stare
at each other for a while unsure of what
to do right then three bullies show up
on the nearby bridge and start teasing
our protagonist calling her piggy they
relentlessly torment her appearance in
body structure forcing her to dive into
the water and hide however even there
the bullies don't stop taunting her the
Shady looking man watches all of this go
down but he doesn't do anything and
simply gets out of the pond surprisingly
we see a lifeless corpse inside the pond
completely tied with chains it is
evident that the man is responsible for
this after a while when the girl
resurfaces from the water believing that
she is out of danger the bullies
suddenly start attacking her with a
fishing net they even take pictures of
her and upload them to the internet the
attack turns out to be so brutal that
the girl starts bleeding from her nose
but fortunately she manages to swim away
when she reaches the other side of the
pond the bullies also prepare to leave
believing that they have successfully
completed their douchebag Mission but
unfortunately for our protagonist they
take all of her clothes and mobile phone
with them in the next scene the girl
frantically gets out of the water and
tries calling out for help but no one is
around so she is forced to go all the
way home in her swimsuit drenched in
water to make matters worse she doesn't
find her shoes making her arduous
Journey even more difficult still
determined to make it home the girl
starts running in the scorching sun when
she reaches the highway a group of
arrogant boys follow her and call her by
the same name piggy a few of them even
grab her and make her feel very
uncomfortable when the situation gets
out of hand the girl takes a detour and
rushes into the woods her eyes are full
of tears and her heart is pounding in
fear she is fed up with the constant
bullying she suffers because of her
appearance as she Ventures deeper into
the woods suddenly the man from the
swimming pool shows up he is carrying
something heavy with him wrapped in
plastic possibly another corpse the girl
is terrified and starts running away but
the man gets into his car and follows
her soon he stops next to her and stares
at her through the window menacingly
then a bloody hand suddenly emerges from
the back seat it belongs to none other
than one of the bullies who is
tormenting her girl earlier the bully
appears to be beaten badly and she cries
out for help this time she even calls
the Girl by her real name Sarah however
Sarah is too shocked to respond as she
stands there in disbelief the man drops
her stuff from the window which the
bullies had taken in earlier this
reveals that he has finished off the
other two already the movie ends as
Sarah nervously thanks the man for his
help and he too waves at her as for the
bully she keeps screaming for help but
Sarah refuses who's the piggy now [__]
[Laughter]
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching